car safety has improved drastically over
the years
and one company appears to be leading
the pack
tesla's have consistently received
five-star ratings from organizations
that perform crash tests
such as the insurance institute for
highway safety one reason you'd be safer
in a tesla is that the electric cars
don't have an engine
so all that steel and aluminum at the
front crumples and absorbs much of the
impact
preventing it from being transmitted to
the occupants
the lack of an engine isn't the only
reason they're safe
it has to do with the overall structure
of the vehicle
they're difficult to roll over because
they have a low center of gravity since
the heavy battery pack and the electric
motors sit low in the vehicle
the american road safety regulator nitsa
determined that the mid-size suv the
model y
has a rollover risk of about eight
percent tesla says that's the lowest
risk of any suv
ever built and lower than the chances of
the model x flipping
over in the unfortunate event that it
does overturn
the tesla relies on the strength of its
roof to protect the people inside
the model 3's roof has been found to
resist more than 20 thousand pounds of
force
nearly six times its own weight or as
tesla points out it can withstand the
weight of about two full-grown
african elephants the part of a car that
offers the least amount of protection
is the side since there's no area
designed to crumple unlike the front and
rear ends
to get over this side panel weakness
teslas have been heavily reinforced with
ultra high grade steel
shown in teal blue while the battery
pack also acts as a barrier
if there is a side collision the model 3
has a thick curtain airbag
that also contributes to a high safety
rating a real world example comes to
mind
in oregon recently the driver of a model
s crashed into a pole hit two trees and
a telephone box
the impact was so severe that hundreds
of small batteries
that work together to power the tesla
were ejected onto the road
despite the damage the driver walked
away with only minor injuries
teslas have also been engineered to try
to prevent accidents in the first place
a safety feature detects when the
vehicle is drifting into another lane
and then steers itself back
and the automatic emergency braking
recognizes obstacles and stops the car
on its own
but there are still some kinks to be
ironed out when european safety experts
euro endcap
tested the braking system on a model x
it avoided hitting a dummy resembling a
child while traveling at 25 kilometers
an hour
but not at 30 kilometers an hour though
it did reduce the speed before impact
this type of technology isn't new volvo
introduced an auto braking function over
a decade ago
but teslas differ because of their more
advanced sensors which should
technically be better at avoiding
collisions
a combination of cameras radar and
ultrasonic sensors help with navigation
the goal is to eventually have the
vehicles drive themselves with no human
driver at all
you might say level 5 autonomy is the
holy grail
tesla's not quite there yet but is
moving in that direction
select customers have been able to beta
test its full self-driving software
which works on both city streets and
highways without any help from the
driver
however the driver still has to pay
attention and be ready to step in
if the vehicle fails to respond properly
so it's not yet autonomous
and if you ask rivals that won't ever
happen the ceo of waymo formerly known
as google self-driving project
dismissed elon musk's company as a
competitor saying he doesn't think
teslas will ever be autonomous
musk fired back tweeting tesla has
better ai hardware and software than
waymo
tesla's full self-driving software is
believed to be propelling its vehicles
from level to autonomy to level three
the tech is a considerable improvement
from autopilot
which is cruise control but fewer
features than full self-driving
and is most often limited to highway use
with any system that isn't fully
autonomous
the driver has to remain alert not doing
so can have fatal consequences
in 2018 a model x on autopilot drove
into a concrete barrier in california
killing the apple engineer who had been
playing a game on his iphone
and failed to take over the steering of
the car although there have been
concerns about the safety of automated
teslas the company has still received
stellar safety ratings with each new
model it produces
but 5 stars is not necessarily
unprecedented
the gas powered lexus es350 and the
electric audi e-tron both scored an
overall safety
rating of 5 on the nitsa scale what's
most important
is the likelihood of someone getting
injured or killed
tesla once touted the mass market model
3 as the safest car
ever built regulators took issue with
that bold statement
in a letter to tesla nitsa accused the
company of misleading consumers
because they said it was inappropriate
to rank vehicles of different weights
tesla shot back saying its statement was
based on nitsa's own calculations
and the scuffle hasn't ended there in
january the government agency asked
tesla to recall 158 000 model s
and model x's over failing touch screens
which it said could increase the risk of
crashes
as of the making of this video tesla
hasn't publicly made a statement
so depending on who you ask it's up for
debate whether teslas are the safest
vehicles out there
but it appears they're leading the pack
and as the technology continues to
improve
the hope is that safety will accelerate
with it
i hope you enjoyed the story i'm cindy
palm just a little bit of an update for
you
for the past four years i've lived in
europe first in paris then in london
but i've recently made the decision to
return home so welcome to my little
studio here in toronto
where i will be bringing you more
stories every single week
i will see you very soon